[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
the king leaving belfast to return to
london in order to be present
when emergency the queen returns
to lie at rest overnight in buckingham
palace
it's perhaps worth bearing in mind
that the soldiers who have with such
care from the royal regiment of scotland
conveyed the queen through much of the
ceremonial we've seen in the last
day and a half
where when she was alive doing normal
military training
and in short time
they have become
prepared
and have delivered the most perfect job
and duty
for their late sovereign
they now receive their headdress back
after marching away
i think to them
the gratitude
of scotland is owed
for the dignity with which they have
protected and looked after the queen of
scots
royal company of archers presenting
their bows
from the center of
edinburgh taking leave of the minister
of st giles and the dean of the chapel's
royal
so tim lawrence and the princess royal
now
start this final journey
so
[Applause]
the longest reigning queen of scots
having received that final royal salute
from the royal company of archers who
were her bodyguard
now making her way through the lawn
market
[Applause]
[Applause]
and a glimpse there of edinburgh
castle's turrets just at the top of
castle
as the journey down
johnson terrace
also lined by lots of scots and others
today
[Applause]
beneath the ramparts of the great castle
the weather has been so
unbelievably good
since the queen's journey from balmoral
began
and scotland really has
bedecked herself with the most
unbelievable beauty to say goodbye to
this
longest reigning
queen of scots
in the distance we can hear the thump of
the drums as the royal company vouchers
marked from the parade their last to
their queen
um
the hearse will turn to the right
towards levian road
the great military barracks in the
castle
built in 1799
looking across the walls that were
rebuilt during queen victoria's reign
down the craggy rock to this road
as it winds around towards
princess street
[Music]
so many people managed to
pay their respects here in edinburgh
while the queen was lying at rest
a fleeting moment for each person
there maybe
having never met
a queen who they felt they knew
[Applause]
[Music]
the queen reflected so much of scottish
life
in her example
and in her determination to serve in
accordance with the commitments she made
at her coronation